hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is the xiaomi me mix 3 you may have
heard of it
it's not really like anything else i've
seen in a while why you may ask
i mean
it's really addicting like come on
anyway let's get into it
[Music]
so the me mix you may remember that name
from the first me mix video i did two
years ago that kind of blew up it was
one of the first bezel-less phones or
you may have picked up that this won my
runner-up for the best design award in
2018. now i want to be perfectly clear
this isn't a review of the whole phone
this is just a deeper look in another
notch avoidance technique
that's become one of my favorite so on
this race to bezel-less phones we have
the standard notch everyone knows it we
have the teardrop notch we have the
infamous bathtub we have the selfie
pop-up we have the motorized chassis and
now we have this the manual slider and i
got to be honest this is one of my
favorite ways to do it so the slide
motion is spring-loaded as you'd expect
so it kind of snaps into place and
that's what makes it click and that's
what makes it this super addicting
motion and also every time you do it
with the volume on you get this sound
effect
and a lighting effect along the sides of
the display where it automatically opens
the front facing camera and then when
you close it as you can see it closes
the camera that makes perfect sense
because that's really the only thing
housed in this particular slider the
back facing camera is already around the
back available anytime and there's no
face unlock on this phone so no ir
blaster it has a fingerprint reader on
the back already so basically the only
thing you need the slider for that you
can't fit in this already tiny top bezel
is the dual front-facing cameras and yes
that is an led flash for your low-light
selfies and actually the only thing i
can get the second front-facing camera
to work with is selfie portrait mode so
it's not like a second wide-angle
front-facing camera or anything crazy or
useful like that but basically just
another sensor for better depth
detection so like i said this this race
for the apparently ideal
bezel-less smartphone of the future has
spawned some of the most interesting
stuff uh doing it this way
has uh its own set of pros and cons the
upside of being a manual slider of
course instead of a motorized one means
no motors so a lesser chance at failure
it's just springs and i'm pretty sure
this motion back and forth is guaranteed
for hundreds of thousands of repetitions
whereas a tiny motor activated by
software i can't be quite so sure and
i'll also say the satisfaction of this
clickiness this addicting feel it's not
the only phone that slides like this
but this is definitely the most 2019 a
slider can get the downside though is it
still is a moving part most smartphones
have zero moving parts so the chance of
failure is greater than zero and
obviously it will increase with any sort
of debris or anything that might get
into this mechanism you got to be
careful about that although i guess with
this one it's not the end of the world
because if it fails you're just losing
your front-facing cameras and some
people might not really take that many
selfies anyway so if you're that person
maybe it doesn't matter as much to you
also another downside would be cases for
this phone is probably not going to get
that many and not just because it's a
slider but more because it's just not as
popular of a line of phones but there is
one that xiaomi makes that comes in the
box which is cool and it works perfectly
the bottom is opened up so the slider
mechanism works perfect and it's more
grippy than glass so if that's your
style then you're in luck and actually
that brings up one of the more
underrecognized things about this phone
this is a really slick phone it's really
slippery and there are other really
slippery phones but that matters more
with this one see there was another
slider phone a couple years ago
this is called the blackberry priv yes i
still have mine and this was also a
vertical slider same mechanism with the
thin display at the front and then the
rest of the components in the back still
spring loaded and of course it had a
full on physical keyboard so then what
they did with the back of this phone is
they made it super grippy it's this
tacky rubberized finish like this is
literally the grippiest phone i own and
that made a lot of sense to do because
to slide the phone open and close you
need a lot of moving around the phone in
your hands so to have a grippy phone to
be able to do that
just felt more secure that way but this
mix 3 is basically all mirror glass and
it's not as dramatic of a slide as the
full physical keyboard but that's a
little more dangerous in the hand if you
have such a slippery back and then of
course it's double dangerous because
glass breaks so the slippery back is a
legit downside it's a con here but maybe
other phones that do this in the future
will use different materials or
different finishes other than that
though it's just a fascinating idea that
you can buy into right now if you want
again it's a moving part and i'm pretty
sure a single grain of sand or just
enough debris getting in here would
eventually become a problem it's hard to
show on camera but if you look at the
right angle you can actually see light
passing through the inside of this phone
which is kind of scary oh and also
another thing i found interesting about
mimics3 obviously you don't need two
earpieces but it kind of looks like this
phone does have that it looks like the
bottom one in the thicker part of the
phone is the real earpiece and the top
part is just this grille that's just a
hollow pass-through so when you slide it
up it passes right through which is
clever and it makes sense xiaomi doesn't
use the earpiece as a second speaker
anyway so it's not used that much it's
also 6.4 inch oled display 3200 milliamp
hour battery snapdragon 845 six gigs of
ram dual front-facing and dual
rear-facing cameras i mean it's a solid
phone again it's not a review but if you
do want to buy into this idea now it's
not a horrible idea you can do it but
what do you think of the whole slider
thing should more phones be doing this
but with better materials maybe
i don't hate it let me know what you
think uh also let me know what you think
of these shorter but more like regular
topical videos i think they're a lot of
fun either way thanks for watching talk
to you guys in the next one
peace